the pandemic changed many people's
working environment some are on a hybrid
model
others permanently working from home
remotely so how do you nurture
relationships with your colleagues
working from home and how does one
advance in one's career
in a virtual environment kirstjen joyce
caught up with an expert who says he
must be very deliberate about it
it really just became the new way of
life for us jake elson is the chief
operating officer for
sae institute north america he's based
in las vegas but oversees the operations
of half a dozen u.s campus locations and
one in british columbia
when the pandemic hit he transitioned to
fully remote
i went from visiting my teams every
other month or quarterly to not seeing
folks face to face
for several months and those in canada
now for over a year
managing an operation with more than ten
thousand students elsa needed to remain
connected
with many of us zoom happy hour seemed
to be a good way to push past the zoom
fatigue and really spend some quality
time socializing and re-establishing
relationships you have to be intentional
that's the hardest part
kimberly b cummings gives about 50
speaking engagements a year on how to
successfully advance in one's career
she says it's all about relationships
and says even in a virtual world
you still need to cultivate your network
so there are four
key relationships that every
professional needs peers teachers
mentors and sponsors
the key difference in mentors and
sponsors are that sponsors
have the influence to pull you from
where you are
to where you'd like to be sometimes
sponsors can be mentors
but not every mentor can be a sponsor
because they may not have the influence
needed
to help expedite your career it's not
too difficult to identify the power
players in your work environment
generally they're the person who speaks
at all the conferences they're normally
selected for key
projects there's generally a buzz about
them when they walk into the room
if you're unsure who that person is i
definitely would ask around
but just how do you maintain all these
different relationships in a virtual
working world
so when you've been in that zoom meeting
and you end ten minutes early
who would you have walked to go get
coffee with ask them to hop on a quick
call or slap them to keep up to date
all of the mentors who you love seeing
once a month in the elevator and you had
a great conversation
reach out to them to have a 15-minute
check-in look for all those incidental
moments
elsin says it was important for his
colleagues to incorporate some levity as
well
friday rockstar bingo sessions with some
of our campuses
we even during the holidays held you
know a virtual white elephant
we really want to just provide just some
fun and interactive sessions to stay
connected
as for networking cummings says today
it's all about deepening the existing
relationships you have
the tip that i always give folks is when
you're on a virtual event
see who is busy in the chat and figure
out
who is the most engaged who who can you
connect with
ask a question yourself that's a great
way to shine the light on yourself a
little bit during a virtual event
and then take that relationship offline
ask for someone to
meet with you for 15 minutes i'd love to
debrief with you about the event that
just happened
kirstjen joyce 8 news now cummings says
her biggest fear is that introverts will
be left behind in some aspect of virtual
work she says they will have to work
even harder
at initiating relationships and contacts